Нова влада. Нові якісні дороги. Наскільки це реально?
Про це ми будемо говорити з виконуючим обов’язки голови Державного агентства
автомобільних доріг України Славоміром Новаком. Доброго дня!
- Дякую, що ви знайшли час для інтерв'ю.
- Дякую, що прийшли.
Президент України Зеленський, як і попередні президенти, тему поганих доріг не оминув
і підписав наказ про створення умов для розвитку та підвищення якості автомобільних доріг.
Треба відремонтувати приблизно 24 000 км основних магістралей.
а це потрібно не менш, ніж 150 млрд гривен.
Наскільки це реально?
24000 кілометрів доріг - цифра, яку ми отримали
в звіті Світового банку в 2017-му році.
Вони його зробили в 2015-му,
дуже просто порахували вартість в цінах з 2015-го року.
Одразу хочу сказати, що йдеться не про 150 млрд.
Буде набагато більше і ми зараз це рахуємо.
Україна майже не має власного виробництва бітумів, тож майже 80% усіх бітумів,
як кажуть, в цілому, ми, тобто не ми, а підрядники,
імпортуємо з Польщі, Білорусі, Туреччини та інших країн.
За 2-3 останні роки  ціна на бітум зросла на 70%.
Спільно з командою президента Зеленського ми готуємо нову програму
на 2020-2025 роки.
24000 за 5 років - можливо.
Тут я рахую на 24000 км
десь приблизно 300-350 млрд грв може бути.
Мусимо бути готовими на щось таке.
Ви обіцяли президенту завершити ремонт міжнародних трас на Нікополь та Кривій ріг.
Чи є фінансування на ці дороги?
Це є доручення президента, щоб пришвидшити роботи.
Будемо шукати, виділяти додаткове фінансування.
Дніпро-Кривий Ріг-Миколаїв - ця дорога… Вона ще не повністю відремонтована.
Нам необхідно ще півтора року,
щоб повністю цю дорогу Дніпро-Миколаїв повністю відремонтувати,
під умовами, що будемо мати забезпечене фінансування.
Зараз іншим пріоритетнім напрямком є Запоріжжя-Маріуполь.
Це дорога життя для Маріуполя,
особливо після блокади Азовського моря.
Ми вже за останні 2 роки 60% вже зробили.
Як буде все добре, то десь в жовтні, в другій половині жовтня,
можемо поїхати відремонтованою дорогою від Дніпра до аж до Маріуполя.
Ця дорога з Маріуполя вона стратегічна для промисловості,
бо морські перевезення переходять на автомобільні траси....
Я трошки вже переживаю за це, тому що як ми перенесемо повністю все завантаження
з портів на дорогу, а не на залізницю, наприклад.
Немає в світі технології, яка може витримати навантаження фури в 100 або більше тонн.
А в Україні так буває, на жаль.
Тут є проблема з ваговим контролем.
Ми робимо автоматичну систему контролю вантажівок в русі.
І якщо є порушення, то штрафуємо автоматично.
І цю систему в цьому році ми вже будуємо на під’їздах до Києва.
Це пілотна програма, яку ми спільно зі Світовим банком реалізуємо.
І сподіваюся, що на при кінці року будемо оголошувати тендер
на вже 100-150 пунктів по всій країні.
Ви відвідували кордони України з іншими країнами. Чи подобаються Вам виїзди і в’їзди в Україну?
Ні, не подобається. Я був і на кордоні з Угорщиною, і з Польщею. І , звісно, що там ще багато роботи потрібно зробити.
Ми на під'їздах до кордону з Польщею маємо забезпечений так званий польський кредит.
І в цьому році починаємо капітальний ремонт під’їздів до КПП на кордоні з Польщею.
З Угорщиною ми покращуємо за рахунок Дорожнього фонду.
Але це все вимагає ще часу, звісно.
Коли Вас призначали на посаду, Ви хотіли зробити такий собі транспортний коридор
з Чорного моря до портів Балтійського моря, щоб пересувалися вантажі Україною зручно.
Чи вдалося це зробити?
Для мене природнім було, щоб коридор, які є золотими воротами портів Чорного моря,
які повинні бути золотими воротами економіки держави, Одеса-Миколаїв-Херсон,
вони були сполучені з портами Балтійського, Північного та інших морів.
І, таким чином, ми визначили коридор від Корчова-Краковець до Львова
і потім зі Львова - Тернопіль, Хмельницький, Вінниця, Умань
і на південь - до Одеси, Миколаєва, Херсона.
І цю дорогу ми за 2 роки на 90% відремонтували.
За два роки нам вдалося дуже багато зробити.
І будемо продовжувати цей коридор в наступні роки.
Паралельно робимо ТЕО - feasibility study для наших європейських партнерів.
Коли вже буде можливість отримувати більше грантів з Європи, наприклад, в рамках Східного партнерства,
ми теж будемо пропонувати цей коридор, цей інструмент.
Скільки в Україні ще трас стратегічних державного,міжнародного значення недобудованих?
Можна сказати, що залишаються ці напрямки, які ми хочемо завершити в наступному році.
Наприклад, Дніпро-Миколаїв - Н-14, Кропивницький-Миколаїв - Н-11.
Це такі дуже важливі дороги, які взагалі знищені. Там тільки напрямки залишилися в частинах.
Частково ми ремонтуємо вже в цьому році, ми ремонтуємо Миколаїв-Кропивницький.
І Кропивницький до кордону з Миколаївською областю.
І починаємо за рахунок окремної бюджетної програми
у розмірі 500 млн ремонтувати вже в бетоні.
Нам вдалося також переконати колег з Брюсселя, з європейських банків,
щоб всю наступну кредитну лінію, яку ми завершуємо переговори з ними,
спрямувати на капітальний ремонт і підвищення категорії дороги до автобана Київ-Одеса.
Тобто, з наступного року починаємо капітальний ремонт цієї також дороги.
Що стосується інших доріг, Київ-Чоп - М06, то цю дорогу утримуємо в більш-менш непоганому стані.
Вона вимагає від Львова на південь до Чопа вже капітального ремонту. Але це майбутні проекти.
Коли Вас призначали на посаду, Ви казали, що 95% доріг в Україні знаходяться в поганому стані,
але для їх відновлення, покращення потрібен час, великі ресурси і зміна підходів до дорожньої галузі.
Що Вам вдалося за три роки?
Перш за все, і насправді я відверто скажу: я не знаю іншої країні в світі,
де за два роки вдалося зробити хоча б дві масштабні реформи в дорожній галузі.
Тобто, створення Дорожнього фонду - як такий незалежний фундамент,
інструмент подальшого розвитку.
Ми вже знаємо, які гроші ми можемо планувати. І децентралізація доріг.
Важко уявити, що, наприклад, перед 2018 роком, коли я прийшов,
всі дороги були об’єктом відповідності "Укравтодору" і Києва.
170000 км доріг - всіх! В Україні.
Зараз за дороги місцевого, обласного значення відповідає ОДА,
а за дороги державного значення відповідає "Укравтодор".
Але чимало українців досі їздять з наліпками "Я ненавиджу "Укравтодор"".
Мені здається, що трішки зменшилася їх кількість.
Але, все ж таки є….
Чи є у Вас якісь рецепт, як зробити так, щоб в Україні були нормальні дороги?
Я постійно чую це питання. Я думаю, що ми вже багато зробили для цього і перед нами зробили.
Потрібен час і фінансування.
Звісно, що я на різних нарадах і конференціях я трошки жартую,
що в кожній дорожні галузі в усьому світі три найважливіші речі: гроші, гроші, гроші.
Я сподіваюся також на додаткові джерела фінансування.
Зараз завершуємо переговори щодо нової кредитної лінії від європейських банків.
Але також і завжди відверто кажу нашим європейським партнерам і друзям,
моїм друзям навіть в Брюсселі.
Як хочете реально допомогти Україні і утримати Україну на європейському напрямку,
потрібно збільшити допомогу не тільки в деклараціях - на словах,
але потрібно допомогти фінансово, збільшити фінансову допомогу.
Найкращій варіант - на інфраструктуру і дороги.
Слава Богу, нам вдалося перший грант в історії України отримати від Євросоюзу.
Він поки не дуже великий – 20 і 50 млн євро.
Але вже перший крок зроблено – двері відкриті. Зараз буде набагато простіше отримати наступний.
Це також моє завдання. Я можу тут допомогти.
Чи вдалося залучити на будівництво доріг іноземні компанії?
Вже є декілька турецьких компаній, декілька німецьких, польських.
Є зацікавлені іспанські компанії в нашому ринку.
Тобто, це є доказом довіри до держави, є доказом довіри до того, що ми робимо.
Тому що всі європейські стандарти, які ми втілюємо в життя зараз, вони зрозумілі також для європейців.
А нам європейські компанії в Україні потрібні, тому що,
так, як вони колись в Польщі принесли інший менталітет,
інший підхід до роботи, іншу культуру роботи, також я сподіваюся на теж саме тут в Україні.
Раніше багато казали, що будівельні компанії, коли вони будують дорогу, немає механізмів,
щоб вони гарантували якість, приміром, на 10 років. Чи вдалося щось змінити ?
Вдалося. Аж важко повірити, коли я прийшов на посаду,
гарантія на будівельні дорожні роботи була рік, або взагалі не було.
Були приклади, коли взагалі не було гарантій.
Від 2018 року всі роботи, які ми робимо середнім поточним ремонтом, мають гарантію 5 років,
капітальний ремонт - мають 10 років гарантії.
Ну вже тут також ми поміняли трішки ситуацію.
І вже підрядники, ми тут дуже жорстко контролюємо, коли виявляємо будь-які недоліки.
Тільки ці недоліки потрібно усунути за рахунок підрядника. І вони почали це робити.
Ви досі виконувач обов'язків голови агентства. З чим це пов’язане ?
Україна не довіряє до кінця менеджеру, якого вона найняла з-за закордону?
Це більше питання до уряду. Тому що призначення керівника "Укравтодору" - це компетенція уряду.
Мені це не заважає, я виконує свою роботу. І чи це ВО чи не ВО - для мене це не має великого значення.
До окружного адміністративного суду Києва надійшов позов
щодо скасування Вашого призначення.
Тобто, це наказ урду, мовляв, можна вважати незаконним, тому що не було конкурсу.
Це означає, що нова влада вас не хоче?
Ні, це є звернення людини, яку я звільнив за дуже серйозне порушення, в тому числі, корупційне.
Там є впровадження проти цієї людини. Мені здається, що це така  помста цієї людини і все.
Я сподіваюся, що все буде згідно з законом.
Ми все пояснимо в цьому суді, і  рішення суду повинне бути за мною.
На початку Ви називали свою роботу такою собі "місією смертника". Як зараз Ви це називаєте?
Насправді я не думав, що буде так важко, що так багато роботи потрібно зробити.
Ми прийшли в пусте поле, нічого не було. Але почали цю роботу, бачу, що потрібно багато речей зробити.
Все буде залежити і від нової також  влади.
Я вже плідно співпрацюю з адміністрацією нового президента,
там є розуміння, є потреба, вони хочуть міняти країну на краще.
Як Ви думаєте, нова влада захоче Вас на посаді чи-то ВО голови державної агенції,
чи-то голови державної агенції? Як це буде?
Я можу тільки зі свого боку сказати, що я - не політик.
Я прийняв запрошення 2,5 роки тому,
щоб допомогти Україні, щоб розпочати масштабні реформи.
Як буде політична воля, щоб продовжити, цю реформу і цю роботу, я готовий співпрацювати.
Звісно, не на кожних умовах.
Перше за все, треба почекати і подивитися,
які будуть перші кадрові рішення, призначення: хто буде прем’єром, міністром.
Я дуже багато присвятив Україні - 2,5 роки без родини.
Моя сім'я живе в Польщі.
Це таке велике навантаження, але ще сила є. І хочу.
Але якщо Україна залишиться на цьому, це особливо  для мене важливо,
тому що я для цього приїхав сюди,
щоб допомогти з інтеграцією в ЄС, щоб можна використовувати мої можливості в інтеграції в ЄС,
якщо Україна залишиться на цьому напрямку - супер! Можемо далі працювати.
Що Вам не вдалося зробити?
Звісно, що хотілося б все робити більше, швидше ще тих речей…
Ну, я кажу, що нам закон потрібен про порядок будівельного ринку.
Я думав, що нам швидше вдасться оголосити конкурс на першу концесію Львів-Краковець.
Ми вже закон поміняли, але ще потрібно оголосити цей конкурс, пришвидшити роботу.
Збільшити обсяг виконаних робіт хотілося би,
але я кажу, що ще потрібен час , потрібні гроші і підтримка.
Якими дорогами Ви порадите своїм друзям з Європи пересуватися в Україні,
щоб нічого не сталося з машиною?
Ми маємо два основні сполучення з кордонами з ЄС до Львова, потім до Києва і до Умані.
Це go high way, це наша пріоритетна дорога, і там можна спокійно їхати.
Вже там невеликі ділянки залишилися по М-12.
Відремонтуємо повністю в наступному році і вже поїдемо з ЄС аж до Одеси прекрасною дорогою.
Також само зі Львова до Києва і з Києва до Харкова будуємо, вона на 90% побудована.
Тобто, спокійно. Всіх моїх друзів з Європи я запрошую. Вже можна поїхати.
Як Ви так добре вивчили українську? Довго вчили?
Добре, Ви кажете. В мене ще, напевно, багато помилок,
і Вам навіть буває смішно, коли я там наголоси мішаю і так далі, і так далі.
Але, я не вивчаю якось
особливо українську мову. Щоденно просто спілкуюся зі співробітниками, людьми.
Я думаю, що коли приїжджаєш в державу, потрібно вивчити мову цієї державу.
А вона прекрасна. Вона дуже схожа на польську мову. Тобто, не дуже важко мені її вивчити.
Дуже дякую Вам за інтерв’ю.
Дуже дякую.